in 1931 the cultural critic Walter
Benjamin wrote an essay titled unpacking
my library which he wrote as he was in
the midst of moving and he saw all his
books stacked up there on the living
room floor he talks about how by taking
the books out of their order the their
kind of structured organizational system
he has in the library and just seeing
them in the kind of chaos of this pile
he started noticing some certain
synchronicities and connections between
these books that he wouldn't have
otherwise noticed and since I'm
currently in the midst of moving I
thought I would do the same thing by
picking a book up off the floor and
seeing what connections and
synchronicities I could find between
that book and another one I have no idea
where this is going to lead me I haven't
prepared any notes about this but I'm
excited to see where this takes us now
for the first book I'm actually going to
choose this one intentionally because
recently the writer David Perell made a
post on Twitter or a where he said what
book do you constantly recommend to
people which was not recommended to you
and I really love that question because
it gave me a chance to think like what
are the real gems on my bookshelf that I
wish all my friends had read and I'm
constantly talking about in conversation
but which was not recommended to me it
was something that I kind of stumbled
upon and immediately this book came to
mind and the reason it came to mind is
that it totally transformed the way that
I think about writing when you look at
at a lot of the writing advice that we
see online these days it really comes
from a place of hustle culture right the
writing advice that we find online is
all about how to boost your productivity
how to make more sales write better copy
all the it's really productivity focused
and it's treating the product writing as
though it's a commodity and this book is
a Manifesto against that approach to
writing it's called The Gift by Lewis Hy
and it's really a meditation not only on
writing but of Art and the difference
between art as a gift and art as a
commodity it's partially anthropology
partially sociology a lot of really deep
rich references to American Literature
and it just gives such a Clear Vision of
what art has been in societies around
the world what it could be when it comes
to our own artistic production and
perhaps what goes wrong when writers
enter the market of writing again it's
not just writing it's a beautiful book
and one that um you know applies to
creativity and artists of all genres so
I'm always highly recommending this book
and it was one that was never
recommended to me I saw it um a friend
of mine was housesitting uh in Canada
years ago and I went to visit her and
this book was there in the living room
it belonged to the owners of that house
I don't know who those owners are but I
picked it up I devoured it that weekend
and I've carried it with me ever since
so now I have to think what book is this
going to link me to well another book
that I read at that same era um probably
within a few months of reading uh the
gift I had also come across this book
which started my Everlasting Love and
obsession with this one writer I had
bought this book uh years before at a um
at a sale at my University I don't even
really know why um I bought it at that
time come to think of it I that writer
um a few of his books had been turned
into movies around that time so I might
have heard of him um it was a really
nice hard cover unfortunately here where
I live now I don't have the hard cover
version um so this is the paperback but
the the addition that I bought that day
was a hard cover um
I I I don't quite know why I bought it
but something about it spoke to me and
it wasn't until probably 3 years later
around the time that I read that book
that I finally cracked into um the book
which remains my favorite book written
by that writer now it's not his best
book um but it is my personal favorite
and that is All the Pretty Horses by
cormack McCarthy what a beautiful book
what a be it's a so if if if you don't
know the writer if you don't know the
the book itself All the Pretty Horses is
what I would call a romance it it paints
a very romantic picture of the um the
American West and the cowboy stories of
old oh my God it tells this wonderful
story and it it's also kind of about the
fading away of that um era uh I remember
that it
opens by talking about how um the Family
Farm had been passed down generation to
generation and for for some reason the
the the father of this boy who who um
John Grady Cole the protagonist of the
story uh his father sells the farm and
it's kind of uh John greedy and his
cousin Rollins it's their
last Last Stand it's it's it's their
last journey into that moment in um in
the American West so it it it it's like
the perfect cowboy story they they go
south they cross into Mexico on
Horseback uh John greedy falls in love
they find work on uh various camps they
they and and they have this real Spirit
about them for the farm and for that
lifestyle which they've Left Behind or
that which has left them you know
they're they're going searching for it
to find some place that can still um
where they can still apply those skills
that they developed on the farm uh
Amazing Story there's this hilarious
character named bevens who comes in who
gets them into a lot of trouble and it
it's just a romance it paints such a
beautiful story of the American West so
if you ever wanted to you know so I said
it's my favorite of his books of course
um cor M McCarthy's best novel has to be
Blood Meridian and that and that story
is kind of um oh I bought this yeah I
bought this one here in Korea um that
story is kind of it Paints the cowboy as
the anti-hero it's kind of a a band of
um bad Cowboys you might say um but here
John Grady Cole is the perfect hero um
it's almost like the the Pinnacle cowboy
story I mean there I I have read a few
other um western novels um but this one
this one really does it for me
again it's the a lot of people get into
corm McCarthy by reading the road
usually this was my first cor M McCarthy
novel and yeah I I completely fell in
love uh with all of his work um but this
and this is the one I come back to God
even to think about it I actually
um I I typed out this entire story
myself because I wanted to get a feel
for it I had heard that Hunter S
Thompson did that with uh The Great
Gatsby and and so I thought well I want
to really figure out what it is that I
love about this story what makes it tick
and so one year um well one yeah one
year no I did it I did it in about two
or three days I think I typed out this
entire story uh not on my computer on a
typewriter so I I still have that
somewhere actually I should dig that up
that'll link me to this classic uh cor
MC McCarthy of course is known as an
American author and the book that we
were just speaking about All the Pretty
Horses was a study of the American
Western novel but what people don't
always appreciate is how close of a
student Cormac McCarthy was for the
Irish novelist James Joyce and this is
his first novel Nolla dep I mean the his
next novels um ulyses and Finnegan's
wake were gargantuan so whether you want
to classify this as a novel or a Nolla
it is an amazing story and one of the
really interesting things about this
book is that it uses a a perspective a
mode of writing called free indirect
discourse so normally whenever we um we
think about the way that stories are
told there might be a first-person
narrator speaking about you know their
own personal experience like um oh
catcher and the Ry would be a really
good example of that you know you're
seeing everything through Holden
cofield's eyes or a third person
perspective such as uh War and Peace you
know where everything is told as though
from a camera cor M McCarthy's novels
are quite like that he he he never
really goes inside the characters but in
Joyce um he's using a mode of narration
called free indirect discourse where
he's not going into the mind of the
character it's it's not a third person
narrator who's telling you okay now
Steven datus was thinking this it's not
really like that it tells the story of
what's going on but the language which
it's chosen is flavored by the
character's interiority so it famously
opens with that might be better to give
an uh an example of it yeah just listen
to the opening sentence here it says
once upon a time and a very good time it
was there was a moo cow coming down
along the road and this moow that was
coming down along the road met a niens
little boy named baby taku okay now that
okay it it's a narration and we haven't
identified a character who's saying this
I mean it's from a Nar
a third person but the words like moow
and even the runon sentence
like it's so childish and like a moo cow
who would call a cow a moo cow but a
little boy and this story is the um it's
a building's Roman so it's it's the
story of a character growing up and
becoming an artist the the book is the
portrait of the Artist as a Young Man
and it famously ends with this really
bold I wonder if I can find it here this
this amazing passage where uh where he
says I will tell you what I will do and
what I will not do where is that you
know what I can't find the passage right
now but I think I know it by heart it it
goes I will tell you what I will do and
what I will not do I will not serve that
in which I no longer believe whether it
calls itself my home my Fatherland or my
church and I will strive to express
myself in some mode of art or life as
freely as I can and as wholly as I I can
using for my defense the only arms I
allow myself to use silence Exile and
cunning it's just such a bold statement
for the kind of artist that Joyce wanted
to become and the next his his next
Works were just such like unbridled
there there was just such unbridled
energy flowing through them ues and then
of course at the at the end of his
career Finnegan's wake so this is like
Joyce's earliest pronouncement of you
know the the kind of modernist writer
that he would become so Joyce leads us
to well I've been talking a lot about
novelists so far and I kind of wanted to
switch gears and start talking about a
poet whose work I've admired for quite a
while I first came across this poet in a
biography I think it was by like
National Geographic or something maybe
PBS but it was about the life of Buddha
it was anime ated I remember and he was
one of the few people who appeared um
you know he was recorded and oh my God
he was just like there was something
very compelling about this guy I wanted
to know who he was he had Crystal Clear
Eyes and um something about the way in
which he spoke about the life of Buddha
that just made it feel so alive and so
real just this just this this room where
we are pay attention to that pay
attention to who's there pay attention
to what's what isn't known there pay
attention to what is known there pay
attention to what everyone is thinking
and feeling what you're doing there and
pay attention pay attention it's clear
that the teachings of Buddha had really
come they they were very real for this
person and I think I was watching this
documentary and kind of learning about
it intellectually but I saw in him
somebody for whom those teachings were
integrated in his life like he he was a
very clear um clear part of well his his
worldview and that is Ws mwin who sadly
uh passed away um well just uh two or 3
years ago now but um wonderful wonderful
poet um and what just occurs to me now
is not I'm going to talk about his poems
in a second but um I I remember reading
uh that when he was younger and kind of
apprenticing to become a poet he visited
Ezra pound who at the time was uh in the
hospital in Europe I believe and um kind
of visited him almost like as a
pilgrimage or something he wanted to
visit the great poet and uh he asked him
for some advice and ezer pound told him
to uh practice translation um so to take
old um you know Italian poets and
Spanish poets and to translate them into
English because that practice itself is
something perhaps like what I was doing
with the Cormac McCarthy novel it's a
way of um you know bringing them in
bringing bringing those voices into your
own but of course with the translation
which is not what I was doing you would
flavor it with his own um interpretation
so anyway that was uh or um that was
Edward pound's advice to Merwin whenever
he came to visit him but the one that I
really remember is um I I I guess Merwin
must have asked pound
what he should be reading and pound told
him to read seeds not twigs and what he
was talking about is go back to the
classics you know read The Works that
have endured um that have endured the
test of time uh which are known oh I can
make a quick pivot here well which are
known um or which are called by Nim TB
in a skin in the game called the Lindy
so the Lindy effect is named after a
restaurant in New York um which actually
closed on the day so a a restaurant in
New York Off
Broadway where um which sold really bad
cheesecake but where unemployed actors
would go and where they apparently
discovered the fact that if a Broadway
musical lasted um what was it uh 6
months then it would last 2 years and if
it lasted 2 years then it would last 4
years something like that in other words
it's the test of time when something is
robust enough to um uh sustain its
existence for quite a while it will go
further and that is what pound was
saying to Merwin don't read these new
contemporary authors these modernists
these you know well at the time of
Merwin it would have been postmodernists
uh don't bother with them go back to the
classics read the seeds not the twigs
and I love that but Merwin is a he's a
wonderful poet um he had this really
interesting style where he he wouldn't
punctuate um almost kind of something
like McCarthy McCarthy used periods and
some commas Merwin didn't use any of
those um but it gave it it gives his
well it it gives his poems something of
um well they're a lot more fluid and
there's a kind of um visual quality to
them like they're not not to be
interpreted as sentences but rather
as well it's it's very visual it's very
imag
provoking oh and I just love this poem I
mean it's a famous one of his poems so
if you know Merwin um you might know
this but in case you don't know Merwin
um I just come across my one of my
favorite poems by him I'll read it for
you here which is called for a coming
Extinction gry whale now that we are
sending you to the end and that great
God tell him that we who follow you
invented forgiveness and forgive
nothing I read as though you could
understand and I could say it one must
always pretend something among the dying
when you have left the Seas nodding on
their stalks empty of you tell him that
we were made on another
day the bewilderment will diminish like
an echo winding along your inner
mountains unheard by us and find its way
out leaving behind it the future dead
and
ours when you will not see again the
whale Cales trying the light consider
what you will find in the black garden
and its Court the sea cows the great Ox
the gorillas the Irreplaceable hosts
range countless and four ordaining as
stars our
sacrifices join your word to theirs tell
him that it is we who are
important I I just find that so such a
powerful pronouncement of the the hubris
of humans um Merwin was a um an
eological poet uh famously he uh planted
um in in towards the end of his life he
lived in a um uh preserve well he turned
his property in Hawaii into a Preserve
of uh palm trees he had like every
variety of palm tree in there um so
definitely an
ecologically um minded poet
and I mean there's a lot that I could
say about this but one one thing I you
know I noted in this reading is take a
look at the capitalization like he's
addressing the gray whale which is about
to become extinct and we're sending him
off to the black garden along with all
these other animals who have gone
extinct and it oh my God it's so um
menacing the way it's saying oh and you
tell that God that we're we invent we
invented
forgiveness and we don't forgive
anything we forgive nothing and of
course uh the end is capitalize as a is
a proper noun but God and him every time
God is referenced
it's not capitalized it it it's so
diminutive and again pointing at the the
human huus yeah I think that's a really
powerful poem but of course you know I
pulled out skin in the game um as I was
talking about Merwin there and this is a
wonderful book um God it's it's a book
that's really hard to summarize um and
intentionally I've heard uh the author
Nim TB say that that um if you have a
book that can be summarized then it's
not going to stand the test of time
because people will just read the
summary so um this book is you know it's
very fractal like okay so skin in the
game like the B the basic message is you
need to in in order
to um survive like like through
evolution in order to become robust in
order to um make intelligent bets in
order to to succeed you need to have
what TB is calling skin in the game in
other words you can't make you can't
make decisions for which you do not feel
the pain of making a bad decision so the
great you know one example of uh that
are you know the war mongers in uh
politics who are calling for war but
they themselves are not going to go to
the front lines and fight and they don't
have children who are going to fight
these wars so they make bad decisions
because they don't feel the pain of bad
decisions and honestly I mean so it's
such a cool book because the way TB
writes um you you can see this lesson
manifest in so many different domains of
life it's not a book about Finance or
business or philosophy it's it's all or
mathematics or probability or and it's
about all of that and more so it's a
very very interesting book but um for
that lesson one place where I see it in
my day-to-day life is you know I work at
a public uh University and the more I'm
there the more I just see like this is a
very inefficient system it's an
inefficient system because we're
receiving public funds so the funding
the the the pay comes not from our
success or Student Success as teachers
but rather from well these artificial
like these artificial measurements
student satisfaction surveys and and
these kinds of things um if we were
actually competitive if we were
exposed to the um the negative
consequences of bad decisions then well
everything would be structured quite
differently we wouldn't have such a
bloated bureaucracy um we would be
approaching our classes uh a lot
differently and you know I mean the
great example of this is look at the
difference between NASA and SpaceX
that's all you need to know okay when
whenever a company has skin in the game
when Elon Musk is putting up the money
for his own own rocket and his fortune
for the the rocket the rocket has to
work right and and and it does and they
do incredible things why because they
have skin in the game when you when when
you're trying to develop um these
Technologies through Public Funding well
it's other people's money and you
personally you know if the as the
engineer uh for example you're not going
to feel such great pain if you blow up
a$ 400 million rocket as he would if it
was your own money another example is
try to play poker with no money you know
try to play it with um pennies or
something it's not as fun and you're not
going to be as uh calculating and
precious about your moves if you don't
actually have money in the pot so that's
the basic message and skin in the game
but it's a fantastic book um the way
that he Blends literature and philosophy
and uh all kinds of different domains to
make the Insight so skin in the game
brings me to this book which is not uh
thematically linked to skin in the game
or um or the other books I've been
speaking about but I I was I just
happened to be reading this book at the
same time that I was reading skin in the
game about 6 to 8 months ago or so and
it's a very interesting book and it just
so happens that at the time I was
starting to read these books I was also
starting a new relationship in my life
and in order to to get to know me my
girlfriend went and ordered these books
from the library and I laugh because
these books are totally unlike each
other at all um so you so she took out
skin in the game and this book which is
mating in captivity uh it's a very
interesting book it's written by um
Esther Perell who is a um she's a Psy
psychotherapist um with uh some very
interesting perspectives about mating
Dynamics and the the title is fantastic
because of course in captivity is the
way that we refer to animals you know
animals in the wild versus animals in
captivity and this book really kind of
brings out the tensions that we find in
modern relationships um and the ways in
which they sometimes contradict our more
natural um animalistic instincts I think
at the time you know when I was starting
that relationship I was really I I you
know I was really in my life I think I'm
just so terrified ending up in one of
these relationships where um oh to put
it crudely you know the two people are
basically roommates you know all all the
romance that we find at the beginning of
a relationship Fades away and now we're
just with our person out of convenience
and because we've entangled our finances
and in other words when the romance
Fades and I've seen that and I just
never want to end up there and that's
what this book really gets to it's like
how do we keep desire alive but the
interesting thing is you know as she she
so she's a um she's really interesting
she's a leanian and laon was a um a
French psychoanalyst kind of dense and a
little um uh you can come across is a
bit of a charlatan in the way that he um
he developed some of his ideas but he
shouldn't people dispense his ideas a
little bit too quickly and I think there
is a lot of baby in that bath water and
so eser Perell um you know has a leanian
understanding of desire and the way in
which it works and I mean maybe you
don't even need Lal maybe it sounds
obvious to say that you only desire that
which you don't have so in relationships
we have this you know notion these days
that our partner needs to be our
everything it needs to be our lover our
spouse our business partner our best
friend all of these roles and if the
partner doesn't fulfill any of those
roles then there's something wrong and
so we wind up just kind of blending with
that person because we we we think we
need to be completely intimate and to
show them every nook and cranny of
ourselves but what that winds up doing
is completely erasing any mystery and
any wonder and therefore removing any
sense of Desire I guess the point here
is that um for relationships to preserve
that flame uh from the beginning we
can't give ourself over entirely to the
other person we need
to maintain our own boundaries and our
own distance so that desire can uh live
in between us in the space
between and so this was a really
interesting book to read with my partner
because it gave us a lot to talk about
in terms of the way we wanted to
navigate through relationship and um
although you know it kind of um raises
some uncomfortable issues about the fate
of um modern relationships I think it
was incredible to get to read this um
alongside somebody skin in the game I I
mean she was just trying to get to know
my head I don't really know how much
that did for her but this was an
excellent book um and I I I didn't buy
it with the plan of um reading it with
um with my partner like that but it went
up being um
uh very fruitful discussion afterwards
so yeah Medan captivity so this is the
graphic novel version of a book I have
no IDE this doesn't totally connect with
M and captivity but I just saw it and I
wanted to pick it off so it's the
graphic novel version of one of my
favorite books but I guess the reason it
jumped out to me is that uh these days
well the author has a new book coming
out and I notice on Twitter there is a
lot of hate for this writer that I
genuinely don't understand um the thing
I really appreciated about this writer
is that well he's he's an exceptionally
clear writer which is an output of clear
thinking he's a very clear thinker he
has a very clear vision of the world
and well and and okay and and the book
is sapiens so this is the Korean version
I got it because I'm well I'm living in
Korea and I'm studying Korean and a
great way to learn well in order to
learn a language you need to have what's
called comprehensible input um so it's
something I talk to my students a lot
about and you know if um and so anything
that helps with your
comprehension assists in language
acquisition and so because I had already
read this book two or three times in
English I thought it would be cool to go
through it in Korean especially because
there are there are pictures to go with
it so that's why I bought this book but
just while I have it here um I really
don't get if if you're one of these
people who hates you Noah Harari I would
love to hear from you in the comments
because I genuinely don't get it it
seems to be that okay I I think the
mistake that he made is that he accepted
invitations to go to like the world
economic forum and talk to leaders at
like Davos and like you know um K CLA
Schwab and these kinds of people um and
so I think he's been become like Guilty
By Association but it's almost like the
way in which nich's ideas were
appropriated by the Nazis like okay and
and they can do with them what they want
but you like n was not a Nazi and you've
all know Harari is not an anti-humanist
a globalist I mean he really celebrates
countries he he does he does argue that
um there are certain problems which
cannot be um which cannot be addressed
through you know a a union of Nations
that there needs to be some um Global
cooperation mechanism and that's true um
I personally am not a fan of these kind
of globalist Trends and I don't really
know how much stock I put in to the
climate Emer Okay because I'm going to
get to because actually um I've been
reading this other book well actually
it's it's in the other room right now
but here's the second book by this
author David Deutsch so I'm going to
come back to Harari for a second but uh
David dech is a physicist at Harvard but
he writes about how basically problems
have Solutions like problems are soluble
and humans are the great explainers like
this is what we do we have problems
those problems lead us into our
investigations in nature we use science
and we discover new knowledge that's
what we do so this whole like you know
climate
catastrophism
um even to the degree to which it is a
problem um does not mean like all these
predictions about how the polarized cops
are going to melt and everything um need
raise no alarm like if okay there is if
there is a problem then there is a
problem but if there's a problem we're
going to solve it we always do and we
always will the world is not going to
end and so coming back back then to
Harari um you know for his
collaborations with organizations like
the IMF like the World Bank that's
probably gotten him a lot of trouble um
and I can see um how people who mistrust
that would also not like to hear from
this vegan Israeli historian who's
telling them we need to you know ban
together but that's not the heart of his
message like they so basically what
they're accusing him of is anti-humanism
they're saying well he is this very
pessimistic outlook on the world and I
don't think anybody who's actually read
him like set aside all the clips taken
out of context from the IMF meetings and
everything like that I don't think
anybody who's actually read Harari
believes that he's a pessimist um one
line that just Springs to mind is um I I
think it was
in where is it now this was his uh his
third book um 21 lessons for the 21st
century and at one point he's talking
about how like if you want to know
what's real how can you tell what's real
and he says well the test to find out if
something is real is to say does it
suffer okay so countries aren't real uh
governments aren't real um the ideas are
not real even like human rights like
these things are not real these are
fictions in hari's worldview and they're
useful fictions like that's one of the
great um Innovations of humans and our
unique language is that we can create
fictions now when he says like human
rights are a fiction people lose their
mind they say he's evil but he's not
he's not saying like we need to dispense
with these he's saying this is the great
Merit of humans and their language but
at the basis of reality for Harari the
the most fundamental thing is humans
humanism like the this is what's real
humans are what's real our suffering is
what's real um incidentally Harari is
like the friend of a friend we both
practice the same um in the same
tradition lineage of meditation and like
I I've just heard he's the most down toe
humble guy there could be so I I really
am sick like I okay I'm not like I would
love to hear from you if you're one of
these like anti Harari guys I would just
I would just love to hear
what which of his ideas you disagree
with and don't talk don't cite any of
the clips from the wef like go to his
writing go to his books find out what he
tell me what he said that is so
disagreeable because I think anybody who
seriously reads him as I have will find
that he's a very clear thinker he has a
very clear optimistic vision of what we
can do in the future so I would love to
hear from you if if you're one of these
anti-h Harari guys I've been trying to
figure that out lately I I really can't
okay one more book one more this was a
cool book again not really a direct
connection to what we were talking about
but um there was a there was a certain
time uh a few years ago I was really
interested in this idea of deep ecology
I guess it's tied in we were just
talking about the climate crisis and
everything and I don't want to come
across like I'm uh I'm some climate
change denier or something like that I
was very interested in uh the
environment and um and yeah so I was
reading a lot about this idea of deep
ecology which is basically like not
seeing nature as a commodity but
actually seeing it as an intelligent
entity and we so we see that in fiction
so um a big book that came out of Korea
a few years ago is the vegetarian and at
the end of the vegetarian there's this
character who might be she's either
becoming a tree or losing her mind um
cuz she's in like an insane asylum um
but I remember at the End of This Book
when she's becom coming a tree she is
doing a headand and she was saying that
like her brain was like the roots of a
tree and her um genitalia was like the
the branches and the the head of the
tree and I thought that's interesting
like okay on CU at first I would think
like if I thought of myself as a tree I
would think of my legs as the roots and
my head as the crown of the tree but
then I thought no that's right like the
roots of a tree are its brain it's the
sensing um nutrient finding organs of of
the tree whereas the sexual organs are
on top it's the flowers and the branches
and and they're all on top so she's
doing a headstand with her uh legs in
the air and and and she's um mimicking a
tree and so that kind of started get got
me thinking about deep ecology and this
idea of like plant intelligence um and I
went on to read this book
which they all seem to kind of come out
at the same time so this book is the
hidden life of trees it's a German uh
arborist I believe he was who um was
writing very um well these were his own
just kind of personal observations of
his life in um uh agriculture he was
noticing the ways like because we have
this idea of nature being red in tooth
nail and Claw is the the so the survival
of the fittest that all these organisms
are competing in an environment of
limited resources um but what he's
finding is just the opposite that you
know when a tree was um Dying For
example other neighboring trees would
send their resources to that tree in
order to sustain it and how these
connections that there's this vast web
of connections between trees in
different iies which are linked by uh
mushrooms and ryom so the ways in which
rise like mushrooms are used almost like
the the neurons in a brain to connect
these trees together it really gave me a
kind of different view of nature as
being a lot more cooperative and um
supportive than is commonly thought of
so that book is called The Secret Life
of trees bonus book that fits uh just in
in line with that deep ecology theme I
read it around the same time wonderful
book called The overstory and this book
really dramatizes the things that you
know the ideas that are put out in this
book so this this this is the first um
this is brilliant because like if you
wanted how would you write a drama about
nature right how would you write a drama
a dramatic story about trees and yeah
like animals well he does it here uh the
author is Richard Powers It's a
Wonderful book winner of the national
book award um so if you ever get
interested in this idea of deep ecology
that would be uh that would be a really
cool book that I would recommend I
actually did recommend this to a friend
and he came back a few months later and
told me that he loved it so highly
recommend the over Story by Richard
Powers so that was a pretty cool tour of
some of the books um and I think that
covers it for unpacking my library hope
that was interesting if it was you can
let me know in the comments I might do
another one um cuz you never really know
where it's going to lead you when you're
going from one book to the other to the
other so if you enjoyed this let me know
in the comments I might try it again
sometime it's going to take me a little
while to finish unpacking my library and
setting up my whole bookcase back there
so um yeah your feedback is appreciated
anyway I hope that was helpful and uh
see you in the next one